[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh a lot of people going like when your
next album coming out
you know i'm like i don't know you know
but a lot of people like you know what
i'm saying uh you know how people
uh wreck the industry you know how they
all we want you to be doing
uh some stuff whatever you know you'd be
like oh
you know what i'm saying a lot of that
a lot of that they came you know some
people they were like what kind of music
you wanna make
you know what i'm saying and i'm like oh
no okay i know i know
[Music]
why are you telling oh
you know what i'm saying but no a long
time ago i got like oatmeal
you know what i'm saying and you know
it's delicious you know that some people
don't like it
some of you don't like oatmeal it's too
bad
real good put some butter in there
there's a brown syrup
sugar stir it up it's just not too hot
so you burn your tongue not enjoy the
rest of your breakfast
regret it later have a sore tongue for
the rest of the week hope that it heals
take some zinc
you know what i'm saying
anyway well i love music that's why i'm
here today um
a lot uh my record label um they told me
to
do some different kind of music whatever
so i'm gonna do a little bit of
different kind of music
and some of the music that i tried to be
doing before is like different kinds of
music you know like that not the same
kind of music
you know when you have music that's like
the same but then suddenly it's not the
same anymore
you know what i'm saying a different
kind of music that's what i'm doing here
so anyways check this out
uh this is a tune uh that they want me
to do was like this
you know what i'm saying i'm like i
ain't gonna do that
and i didn't uh and i did a two and it
was like this
you know so i finally found a type of
music that i like there's a there's a
music the black people make
uh this is called black people music uh
this is music
uh called uh funk uh rv uh so i hope you
enjoy it
uh even if you're not black i think you
might like it so um
go like this
[Music]
now sometimes you might need some
accompaniment so you know you might need
someone like
mr vevino for instance there you go yeah
that's right
oh yeah oh yeah
and you might do something like this
[Music]
yeah maybe some more real bass in the
real band yeah
[Music]
i can't be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
asking you one more time one more time
that's great ricky wants everybody